[Musique]
bonjour chez vous à l'heure de la
présidentielle bonjour à tous et merci
de nous rejoindre nous vous proposons
une série d'émissions spéciales nous
recevons les candidats avec les
journalistes de la presse régionale et
pour ce premier numéro nous accueillons
eric zemmour bonjour au revoir merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation êtes candidat reconquête
c'est parti vous avez fondé il ya
quelques semaines et nous sommes
ensemble pendant une heure et avec les
journalistes de la presse régionale nous
avons choisi de vous interroger sur les
thèmes sur lesquels on vous entend moins
et qui pourtant font partie des
préoccupations majeures des français en
parlera des déserts médicaux de la
hausse des prix de désindustrialisation
d'agriculture et pour vous interroger
six journalistes de la presse régionale
à mes côtés christelle bertrand bonjour
christelle bonjour du groupe la dépêche
bonjour eric julien lécuyer de la voix
du nord bonjour julien bonjour au
royaume est en duplex depuis leurs
rédactions locales eric zemmour guilhem
rica vide du journal la provence qui se
trouve à marseille luc bouriane de l'est
républicain le groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france qui lui
se trouve à nancy alexandre charrier de
la république du centre qui est à
orléans et jefferson des sports de sud
ouest qui lui se trouve à bordeaux
mais d'abord eric zemmour l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est la sortie de ce livre
les fossoyeurs ce livre qui fait état de
graves dysfonctionnements au sein des
ehpad du groupe français au rhdp a
accusé d'avoir mis en place un système
qui maltraitent nos aînés alors le
groupe dément le gouvernement va
convoquer le directeur général du groupe
que doit faire l'êta selon vous ce qu'il
aurait dû faire depuis longtemps ne pas
attendre
qu elle est assortie d'un livre
des choses que l'on savait
qu'ils couraient depuis des années moi
je me souviens d'en avoir parlé lorsque
j'étais chroniqueur à face à l'info je
me souviens parce que je n'avais vécu
moi pour ma mère est
encore j'avais eu la chance d'être dans
un établissement parisien mais j'avais
pu voir déjà
comment ça se passait si vous voulez la
médiocrité des repas et encore moi à
l'époque les infirmières et les
aides-soignantes était adorable et
charmante avec ma mère c'est un
établissement de ce groupe ou par non je
pense que mon nom je pense pas non je
vous dis c'est global en fait qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé on le sait
ce sont des gens des fonds de pension
souvent américains qui investissent là
dedans car c'est très rentable en vérité
il y a c'est souvent le cas en france la
rencontre entre une socialisation
collective par la sécurité sociale dont
les remboursements etc et puis des gens
qui font un argent fou qui sont le
rendez une rentabilité extraordinaire
est qui et qui ne sont là que mû que par
des ddd des sentiments et des volontés
de rentabilité est évidemment tout est
sacrifié à cette rentabilité
on a manqué de régulation sur ce sujet a
pour le moins oui là vous maniez la
litote
les réguler qu'est ce qu'on fait et ben
vous savez le système français est très
paradoxal on a d'une part une excessive
bureaucratie
par exemple les ars que moi je propose
de supprimer entre les ars qui
contrôlent joly va bien s'est
secrètement ce que j'allais vous dire
ils sont ebe bureaucratise voyez la
bureaucratie stay soleil pinaille pour
des choses et c'est pour ça que je vais
vous dire le paradoxe est en même temps
il ne contrôle pas l'essentiel bcc qui
devrait contrôler ou chantal et à wayaux
je vous dis moi je pense ged qui le
préfet le je pense que les ars ont
montré leur inutilité voir leur le côté
visible donc il faut les supprimer vous
savez qu'en france on si on avait à lui
à peu près que dans le système
hospitalier à 30% d'administratifs en
plus par rapport au système allemand
sont des chiffres qui ont couru pendant
tout l'épidémie ya aucune raison donc
donc il faut à la fois débureaucratiser
et avoir un vrai contrôle de l'état
sérieux c'est pas s'est passé vous en
vous embauchez des deux nouvelles
personnes parce que finalement les
services préfectoraux les services
préfectoraux ils n'ont pas que ça à
faire à l'heure actuelle donc j'imagine
que pour les contrôles vous devez
embaucher des deux nouvelles personnes
pour assurer ces essais mais sans doute
qu'il faut un contrôle en amont avec une
une formule de d'agrément on pourrait en
trouver j'imagine améliorer le contrôle
en amont à qui on donne la gestion de
ces ehpad
exiger des des clauses voyez pour bien
être sûr que tout ne va pas être
sacrifiée à la rentabilité pour le la
nourriture pour les soins pour le nombre
de personnels plutôt le contrôle au fil
de l'eau ou non qui dois je pense que
c'est les contrôles en amont ces jeux un
désagrément il se disait oui mais je dis
bien sûr mais d'après moi ils ne sont
pas assez sérieux si on a ça c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas assez sérieux de
votre point de vue c'est à dire gens qui
seront dans les maisons de retraite pour
vérifier que les repas sont bien on est
des cabanes moi je vais vous dire
j'aurais bien aimé oui avec ma mère oui
c'était
physiquement non on vous le dit c'était
un mangeable vraiment je vous assure on
va passer on va passer un objet non mais
je beaucoup de tests qui s'est ralliée
où je vous parle vraiment de 2,2 ce que
j'ai vécu je m'empresse été cités comme
beaucoup de oui bien sûr comme beaucoup
de français on imagine que vous attendez
vous attendez quoi des sanctions de la
part de l'état qui va convoquer le
directoire du groupe parce que vous
attendez vie c'est la moindre des choses
mais ces voiliers séparer faut pas
réagir ponctuellement il faut il faut
une politique globale je reproche à gogo
à l'état c'est de ne pas avoir fait ça
en amont ce que je vous ai dit au début
on va parler de la défense continue à
parler des questions de santé on va
parler des questions de déserts médicaux
puisque c'est l'une des préoccupations
majeures des français on va aller dans
la région la plus touchée par cette
problématique le centre val de loire en
layon retrouver alexandre charrier de la
république du centre bonjour alexandre
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous et le
centre val de loire on disait la région
la plus touchée par cette problématique
des déserts médicaux
oui c'est un problème qui qui ne fait
qu'empirer depuis depuis plusieurs
années à titre d'exemple dans le loiret
sur l'année 2020
ce sont 80 médecins généralistes qui ont
disparu qui ont raccroché qui ont quitté
la région très concrètement cela veut
dire aujourd'hui qu'ils allaient
médecins qui ont 2000 3000 jusqu'à 4500
patients à s'occuper en particulier dans
les régions dans les territoires ruraux
et qui de ce fait ne prennent plus de
nouveaux malades évidemment puisque
puisqu'ils sont déjà à saturation
dans la région centre où on estime qu'il
ya un quart des gens qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant aujourd'hui ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que ce sont des
gens qui tournent ne sont pas suivis
régulièrement ils tournent vers les
urgences
quand ils ont un problème est souvent
quand il arrive dans l'urgence c'est que
le problème est déjà grave il savait
déjà que cette inégalité cette inégalité
d'accès au soir elle est synonyme de
perte de chance très concrètement pour
les patients donc le tableau il est bien
sombre et on voit pas la lumière au bout
du tunnel parce que l'autre chiffre qui
inquiète dans le loiret c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui près d'un médecin sur deux
un médecin généraliste sur deux qui a
plus de 60 qui a 60 ans ou plus
équilibre dont va partir en retraite et
relais prochainement dans ma question
est les courbes de 7,2 cette liberté
d'installation du médecin
est ce qu'aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
anachronique au bilan de la situation
que moi un combi et comment vous comptez
faire en sorte que les praticiens soient
mieux réparties sur le territoire et
qu'on ait les mêmes chances de se faire
soigner qu'on habite à orléans chartres
auxerre ou à biarritz nice qui sont des
villes bien mieux dotés aujourd'hui
voyez cela peut partir des mêmes
prémisses
de cette discussion que de la discussion
précédant c'est à dire le racontera les
contradictions et les paradoxes d'un
système français qui est à la fois
socialiser puisque tout est remboursé
par la sécurité sociale et en même temps
qui est libéral puisque les médecins
sont des professions libérales qui qui
qui ne sont pas salariés qui exercent
librement leurs activités etc tu peut
s'installer où elles veulent servir ce
mélange kiki et qui peut être subi et
très profitable si c'est équilibré et
harmonieux et qui peut partir comme ça
et d'être déplorable quand ce n'est plus
de tenue et là nous sommes à un moment
que c'est plutôt nu pourquoi parce
qu'une fois de plus nous avons fait les
gouvernements précédents ont fait des
choix
de courte vue je m'explique à partir des
années soixante dix et plus encore on a
mis un numerus clausus aux études
médicales pourquoi parce que les
technocrates de l'époque se sont dits
très intelligemment croyait-il et ben
voilà il ya des déficits de la sécurité
sociale c'est les médecins qui font des
ordonnances donc c'est les médecins qui
provoque des achats de médicaments donc
s'il ya moins dans 10 à moins de
médicaments il y aura moins de
médicaments achetés et moins de trou de
la sécu siamois d'ordonnancé donc s'il
ya moins d'ambiance et qui en moins de
médecins donc on a réduit au
gouvernement et met fin au numéro le
gouvernement il ya mis fin dans les mots
dans les mots ce n'est pas encore dans
les faits voyez ça ça prend du temps
c'est belge vous avez raison c'est vrai
ça prend du temps mais il faudrait aussi
activable mais et c'est ça le scandale
d'origine ce qui fait que alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait maintenant ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant d'accord non mais
je joue c'est quand même important de
savoir vous avez les conséquences des
décisions alors donc maintenant au fait
vous avez raison la première mesure de
long terme parce que les études
médicales ces six ans huit en dix ans
donc évidemment ça va prendre du temps
c'est en finir avec ce numerus clausus
moi je propose de doubler la capacité le
2 2 2
de promotion des deux promotions
annuelles voyez de formation des
médecins ce qui évitera que des jeunes
français aillent en belgique parce que
le concours est moins difficile pour
être
titré les ce qui évitera d'ap de de
faire venir des médecins algériens ou
roumains ce qui prive ces pays là ça va
très bien on va en parler juste sur la
liberté je continue sa nation alors à
combien je ne sais quand même le
problème de fond deuxièmement
deuxièmement en urgence en urgence parce
qu'il ya des urgences vous avez montré
je propose des d'imiter le département
de saône et loire qui a embauché 70
médecins salariés pour 5 ans payé par le
département de fer sont dans tous les
dans tous les déserts médicaux de vos
bouchées mille médecins pour ça pour la
france entière oui pour la bête dans les
déserts médicaux bien sûr va marie là si
vous demandez aux jouets l'éctivité de
le faire par exemple entourait ce soit
l'état qui le sait l'état qui pourrait
le lait payé soit lille les
collectivités a pressé de la répartition
administrative voyez pas ce que met on
pas plutôt à la collectivité histoire
qu'elle y met le département de saône et
l'a fait voilà ce serait plutôt sur ce
mode absolument deuxièmement
deuxièmement bien trouver où ces mille
médecins parce que je sois l'information
je vais vous savez il ya pire a lancé ce
que j'allais vous dire ça c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire ce que je comprends
dans l'évolution du 2d des médecins
votre journaliste a dit il y en a
beaucoup qui vont partir c'est normal
c'est les boomers c'est les gens qui
règlent est sonné et eux ils
travaillaient beaucoup
aujourd'hui les médecins travaillent
beaucoup moins c'est aussi une des
causes du problème c'est à dire que ils
font beaucoup moins d'heures et donc il
peut voir beaucoup moins de médecins une
bombe en zone rurale et ça c'est le
deuxième problème mais il ya là le
premier c'est qu'ils font moins d'heures
même s'il allait aux zones rurales et le
deuxième problème c'est qu'ils ne vont
pas aux zones rurales oui il ya deux
problèmes consécutifs donc deuxième
chose parce que vous m'avez coupé
il y avait il y à aussi vous savez bien
que les yeux ou l'avez dit vous-même les
hôpitaux sont surchargés les urgences
des hôpitaux fonctionnent et pourquoi
parce que auparavant il y avait un
système de garde
c'est à dire que les médecins étaient
obligés de faire un système de garde
comme les pharmaciens mais même les
vétérinaires et j'ai appris deux il ya
peu eh ben je il a été supprimé ce cette
obligation de garde pour les médecins en
2003 par jacques chirac je pense que ce
fut une erreur donc vous rétablissez cet
oubli gré exactement je rétablis cette
obligation de gars je pense que c'est
vraiment important
donc ça ne réglera pas tout josu de la
corde mais en tout cas au moins ça va
désengorger les urgences et ça va
permettre si vous voulez j'établis donc
dans tout les déserts médicaux des
centres de prévention d'urgence avec il
y aura un interne enfin vous voyez
si je comprends bien journalier à
l'urgence vous établissez un garde voilà
et lorsqu'il emile des 1000 médecins
c'est pas possible immédiatement bas le
plus vite possible et savent en
saône-et-loire ça marche qui existe déjà
sur il valait le salarié parce qu'en
fait ce que j'ai compris et mon but j'ai
parlé avec le nantais pas faim la
liberté d'installation de l'année alors
ça ça ce jeu pour l'instant je ne met
pas fin à la liberté d'installation
pour l'instant oui parce que j'estime
que il faut une réflexion là dessus moi
je respecte tout à fait elle le côté
libéral des médecins mais je considère
que
ils ont fait des études importantes et
c'est que voyez il ya ils ont droit en
considération mais aussi tout est payé
par l'état il ya peut-être des des
contraintes je voyais à voir maintenant
je rétablis des contraintes lagarde et
pour le tour l'obligation je pense qu'il
faut évaluer
je pense alexandre charlier à une
question pour vous justement sur les
médecins étrangers alexandra les oui
parce que sur la question d'une emile
médecin vous n'avez pas tout à fait
répondu à mon avis sur effectivement ce
ce réservoir de milly médecin
aujourd'hui il n'existe pas il n'y a pas
un mille médecins qui sont formés qui
allie méritoire est ce que aujourd'hui
l'urgence elle passe du coup par le
recrutement de médecins étrangers comme
peuvent le faire de nombreuses communes
nous dans le loiret où on a des médecins
roumains des médecins grecs qu'ils
veuillent qui viennent prêter main forte
et répondre à l'urgence et aux besoins
des patients actuels comme je je je vous
savez bien que ma candidature
est mise sur le principe même
désormais du refus de l'immigration donc
c'est pas moi qui vais vous dire oui il
faut encore plus d'immigrés non moi je
pense que il faut moins d'immigrés et je
vais je fais campagne pour l'immigration
zéro maintenant je fais une distinction
entre les européens et les autres
premièrement mais deuxièmement je tiens
à dire que c'est un peu facile de dire
il faut faire venir des immigrés pour
faire venir des étrangers parce que nous
payons l'impéritie des gouvernements
précédents loin je connais beaucoup de
médecins de gens qui n'ont pas pu
justement être médecin pour un quart de
point pour un demi point et ça ce sont
des jeunes français donc jolie médecins
roumains qui sont actuellement il le
loiret pour pallier les moules de
médecins qu'est ce que vous leur dites
rester dans leur essai dans le loiret on
a tombé je vais pas les chasser donc il
reste bien sûr mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup de médecins jojo show voyez ça
parce que je discute avec les maires
j'ai même discuté avec le président du
conseil général dont je vous parlais de
saône et loire qui a fait ce que je vous
ai dit il m'expliquait que il ya
beaucoup de médecins qui viennent de
roumanie par exemple et qui repartent en
vérité ils viennent prendre quand ils
sont bien payés ils ont tous frais payés
ils ont dans un appartement payé etc etc
il ya un peu d'effet d'aubaine quoi
merci alexandre charlier merci beaucoup
pour vos questions depuis orléans
questions sur la décentralisation oui
mais qui est tout à fait en lien avec le
domaine de la de la santé ce que vous
vous souhaitez donner compétence aux
maires et aux régions sur les conseils
des questions de santé
je pense que la santé est une compétence
nationale elle doit le rester elle doit
le rester alors même que les
associations début type régions de
france ou bien association des maires de
france se plaide justement pour cette
décentralisation
jeune eugénie suis pas favorable je
pense que la santé est une
responsabilité nationale
et que nous devons la laisser à l'état
maintenant moi pour l'heure les
répartition des pouvoirs entre les
différentes strates administratives
je suis favorable au retour de des
compétences du maire je pense que la
décentralisation a été très perverse
c'est à dire que l a paradoxalement
dépouiller le maire de toutes ses
compétences ou de la plupart de ses
compétences qu'ils ont été arrachés par
la région le département la communauté
de communes comme comme ceux ci le cela
et je discute je me savais je passe en
france tous les autres ont tous les deux
vraiment dans toutes les régions de
france et à chaque fois j'organise un
déjeuner avec des maires
je vous assure que tous se plaignent de
ce fameux millefeuille administratif
kylie kylie qui les prive de toute
compétence alors que par ailleurs ils
sont quand même responsable devant l'art
abstrait les jusqu'au bout est ce qu'il
faut supprimer des couches de ce
millefeuille administratif pour essayer
en tout cas en tout cas on va pas en
faire un thème de la commune serait trop
compliqué et puis que les et puis que
tout le monde se plaint du changement
permanent par exemple des grandes
régions de monsieur hollande qu'on était
une catastrophe
qu'il faudra non mais il faudra étudier
cela parce qu'effectivement il faut
simplifier avec deux principes le
maximum de compétences pour les mères
retour à la compétence la subsidiarité
succès et dont j'ai fini et la
simplification
car aujourd'hui nous sommes sortis de
lait pur
napoléonienne l'état le préfet et le
maire et on a cru que ça allait faire
des économies et que ça allait rendre le
pouvoir à la base c'est tout le
contraire on a dépensé dix fois plus
d'argent et en plus le pouvoir a disparu
de là bas juste une petite question les
maires réclament réclame le contrôle des
finances est ce que vous remettez la
taxe d'habitation
vous savez ça a été une erreur
macron oui de la supprimer parce que ça
à priver les mères d'une autonomie
fiscale mais maintenant c'est très
difficile de remettre la taxe
d'habitation moi je plaide pour en
compter à une baisse des impôts et des
charges massives parce que j'estime que
nous sommes sûrs à poser dont vous voyez
c'est je veux pas commencer par voir
rétablir un appeau aller christelle on
va parler du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'annoncé hier de jean castex oui bien
jean castex a annoncé une hausse de 10 %
du barème de l'indemnité kilométrique
est ce que c'est une bonne mesure qui
selon caisse tout et tout est bon pour
permettre aux gens de de tenir face à
cette folle poussée inflationniste mais
c'est du bricolage si vous voulez il
faut comprendre ce qui se passe il faut
il faut voir pourquoi on en est là et
pour comprendre après pour pouvoir
prendre des mesures utiles ehpad et
mutilent des mesures de simples
réactions comme tel gouvernement je suis
sidéré le gouvernement vraiment gère au
fil de l'eau il ne prévoit rien parce
qu'en fait pourquoi on en est là ben
voilà pourquoi on en est là d'abord une
raison de fond qui est indépendante de
tout le monde il faut être honnête c'est
la reprise économique après le le nez
sur la langue par ne plus être
malhonnête dans une conversation j'ai
une discussion la première chose c'est
ça mais ce n'est pas que ça
c'est aussi que si vous voulez on paye
les mesures vertes c'est à dire qu'on
paye l'écologie on est en train de payer
le fait que dans beaucoup de pays en
particulier l'allemagne on a fermé des
centrales nucléaires la france à fermer
fessenheim une décision absolument
stupide de la part d' emmanuel macron et
en plus à cause du coc vide à cause du
vide on a une quinzaine de centrales
nucléaires qui ne qui sont à l'arrêt
parce qu'on manque de de gens pour pour
vérifier évidemment pour pour assurer la
sécurité la hausse du prix du carburant
une dizaine à huy attendez je vous
assure je vais continuer d'accord vous
allez voir vous allez comprendre ces
traces est assez simple mais il faut un
peu de raisonnement donc on a réduit la
la la la les investissements on arrête
dans le nucléaire on a réduit aussi dans
les centrales à charbon qu'est ce qui
reste on a réduit les investissements
dans le pétrole donc deux conséquences
moins de quantité de pétrole ont ceux
des prix raisonnement classique plus et
2 qu'est-ce qui reste avec tout ça le
gaz
poutine est très heureux poutine est
ravi de la victoire idéologique des
verts de monsieur jadot et autres et de
monsieur hulot le grand bénéficiaire
c'est monsieur poutine qui peut vendre
son gaz très cher d'autant plus qu' il a
profité de la jobardise de la commission
de bruxelles parce qu'il leur avait
proposé il y a quelques années un prix
stable et fixe sur plusieurs années et
que messieurs de la commission de
bruxelles
entiché d'idéologie libérale et de
liberté des prix de l'eau dit mais non
mais non c'est le marché qui décidera et
bat le marché décide et donc qu'ils
payent nous donc il faut réinvestir dans
nucléaire et dans les centrales à
charbon
les centrales à charbon évidemment que
non mais je vous signale quand même que
pendant qu'on fait nous
les vertueux les chinois ont ouvert des
dizaines de centrales à charbon là en ce
moment donc voyez pour pour le pour le
climat c'est une catastrophe sauf que je
dis c'est qu'effectivement il faut
réinvestir le nucléaire donc je vois qu
emmanuel macron comment j'ai fini je
suis très bien ici je vais vous répondre
je vois qu emmanuel macron après quatre
ans et demi de tergiversations et même
de politique anti nucléaires découvre
les mérites du nucléaire est formidable
maquereau au moins son quinquennat
n'aura pas servi à rien qu'est ce qui
l'a fait au début qu'est ce qui l'a fait
au début je voudrais rappeler autant de
monsieur hulot qu'est ce qu'il a fait 1
il annonce que le nucléaire sera réduit
à 50 % de la part de l'électricité pour
dire aux gens il est maintenant il est
en ce moment à 75 88 102 il annonce la
fermeture de 12 réacteurs nucléaires
3 il se débarrasse d'une technologie
française en pointe qui permet de
retraiter les déchets pour refaire de
l'énergie la fameuse technologie astrid
je vous signale que bill gates est en
train de proposer aux amis au
gouvernement américain de reprendre
cette technologie toujours les gros
malins de français qui invente tout et
ils ont des dirigeants tellement
intelligent qu'il s'en débarrasse mots
et maintenant donc oui il a fait tout ça
il à fermer fessenheim il n'était pas
obligé du tout c'était le pouls
connaissait l'histoire je la connais
bien c'était l'accord de d'arrière
cuisine politicienne entre madame aubry
qui était premier secrétaire à l'époque
du ps et les verts on y revient toujours
les mêmes pour avoir quelques
circonscriptions et du coup madame aubry
s'est engagée à fermer fessenheim voilà
la grande politique de nos compétences
et d'un lien direct au congo alors
combien de divisions absolument vous
avez raison que moi ce qu'il faut c'est
un
proto construire 14 réacteurs nucléaires
14 il faut prolonger il faut prolonger
la durée de vie des centrales actuelles
à 60 ans les américains le font et
ensuite il faut aurait utilisé et
remettre au goût du jour technologie
astrid parce que nous avons toujours
mais vous savez vous savez c'est très
grave ce qui est en train de se passer
car le gouvernement pour des raisons
démagogiques est en train de tuer edf le
gouvernement et l'europe est-ce que j'ai
une minute pour expliquer ça parce que
c'est
mais ils ont tout à fait raison est ce
que pour vous la décision de demander
des f2 vendre à bas coût les prix à ses
concurrents c'est une erreur ah c'est
pas non bien sûr on va me dire il faut
faire c'est pour protéger les gens sauf
que ça qu edf vous savez que ça leur
coûte angie arnaud lemaire que c'est
normal qu edf contribuer à voile et
marité débat voyons et ben voyons alors
j'ai une minute vraiment parce que c'est
un pur une minute passe d'emmanuel à
bordeaux une minute vraiment une mine
mais c'est très important pour expliquer
aux gens ce qui se passe et comment on
est en train de bavarder un le legs de
dd français et du général de gaulle edf
qu'est ce qui se passe depuis des années
la commission de bruxelles encore une
fois au nom de son idéologie libérale a
exigé du gouvernement français qui a
cédé qui s'est soumis que edf pour
inventer des concurrents parce que c'est
vraiment ça on invente des concurrents
vendent son électricité qu'elle produit
dans ses centrales nucléaires un prix de
42 euros le fameux tarif à rennes
évidemment les grands groupes se sont
précipités en jeep total évidemment ça
ça coûte pas cher et y revendre plus
cher
le résultat c'est que edf depuis des
années ne peut plus investir parce
qu'ils ne gagnent plus assez d'argent
et donc l'établissement public le
service public ce qui a été fait par les
français et a été spolié par des groupes
des grands groupes privés première chose
ensuite aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se
passe cette électricité elle a tout
vendu à edf pour 2022 à 42 ans
le prix de l'électricité aujourd'hui
vous savez combien les 250 euros voire
300 euros le kilowatt heure donc est ce
qui se passe quand monsieur le maire dit
il faut vendre plus excités et il faut
un prix réduit edf doit acheter sur le
marché libre de l'électricité à 250
euros qu'il va vendre à des grands privé
à 42 euros bravo monsieur le maire je
dois dire que là c'est trop fort et une
dernière question rapidement eric
zemmour ce matin qu'est ce que vous
dites aux français qui ont du mal à
faire leur plein comment vous allez les
aider à payer cet esprit alors il faudra
étudier
effectivement en urgence parce que je si
vous voulez moi j'essaye toujours de
prendre des mesures pérennes sur tous
les sujets parfois c'est mal compris
comme sur locaux vides je suis assez
content qu'un an après la situation me
donne raison mais sur le moment où on
s'y met mais d'où ça sort donc moi je
pense que il faut et peut-être sans
doute taxer et bloquer les taxes sur
l'essence mais c'est provisoire j'ai
proposé une mesure qui ressemble à ce
que nous vivons nous dans les métropoles
sayah vous savez on est tous salariés et
on a le remboursement de notre carte
panneaux carte navigo de transport en
commun à moitié à moitié prix les 50% je
propose ça il ya huit millions de
français qui vont travailler en voiture
donc je propose la même mesure pour le
tarif km à l'obligation faite aux
entreprises de rembourser à exact des
dépenses il ya déjà des entreprises qui
le font et je propose parce que je pense
que là les les salariés doivent être
protégés est-ce que c'est qu'on fait est
ce qu'on a c'est un bordeaux est-ce que
ses valises et que c'est
possible avec la transition écologique
on sait qu'il faudrait utiliser un peu
moins de voitures écoutez moi je pense
que la transition écologique c'est bien
mais si elle ne
ruine pas les français et si elle ne
détruit pas l'industrie automobile
française or nous sommes en faire deux
en train de faire les deux
nous avions parlé non si on va à
bordeaux on va à bordeaux retrouvé
jefferson des sports qui est journaliste
à sud ouest bonjour jefferson merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on va parler
avec vous de la transition écologique et
de l'avenir de la filière aéronautique
bonjour en rien eu
à les aider faire ça nous fois de
questions bonjour eric zemmour je mets
ça va faire le lien avec ce qu'on vient
d'évoquer un nouvel un kit nerfs les
romantiques pèse 70 emplois directs
c'est une filière éprouvés par la
pandémie mais c'est aussi une filière au
coeur de la question environnementale la
navette aérienne hors du porzou été
supprimée parce qu'il ya une alternative
entre
vous le savez ma question est simple
cette suppression de la lune henry
bordeaux est une disposition de la loi
climat si vous êtes élu est-ce que vous
reviendrez sur cette disposition est ce
que tu as est génial et coûté 7,7 ligne
je crois
air france n'est pas n'est pas gêné
qu'on la ferme parce qu'en vérité elle
perdait beaucoup d'argent car les gens
vous savez à moi à moins de trois heures
les gens prennent le train moi le
premier pour aller à lyon pour aller
même à marseille pour aller à aix pour
aller à bordeaux on prend tous le tgv
c'est une évidence donc l'amiable avec
cette disposition a des problèmes mais
encore une fois c'est toujours la même
chose on n'est pas obligé de prendre des
mesures coercitives et n'oublions pas
vous avez raison à toulouse nous avons
une de nos rares industries compétitives
ne l'a sacrifions pas une fois de plus
sur l'autel de notre idéologie justement
quel est l'avenir de la filière
aéronautique quand on voit que ces
petites lignes sont supprimées les unes
après les autres pour pour des raisons
environnementales
oui et puis de concurrence avec le tgv
je vous dis même sans toi je vais vous
dire ce que je vous ai vous dis donc
même sans le climat oublions oublions le
climat pour aller à lyon et à bordeaux
honnêtement je prendrai toujours le
train je me dis pas c'est pour protéger
le climat c'est parce que voilà c'est
plus confortable c'est plus facile on
n'attend pas une heure aujourd'hui c'est
lyon bordeaux demain ça peut être
d'autre non parce que plus vite on a
bien oui ce que je veux dire bon
d'accord on ne gagne pas beaucoup de
temps on va moins vite que le temps du
concorde donc je vois pas ce que je veux
dire aéronautique parce que toulouse est
effectivement je suis justement moi je
crois si vous voulez d'abord je d'abord
avant tout moi je suis là pour protéger
l'industrie française jeu les
considérations climatiques c'est bien
mais
si vous voulez nous représentons 1% de
la production de co2 dans le monde
donc la france n'a pas à se fustiger et
à se flageller aux permanences et à
sacrifier son industrie sur l'autel des
considérations climatiques que les
américains et les chinois commencent
d'abord ça sera très bien que les
chinois ferment leurs centrales à
charbon les américains aussi que les
grands commence et nous suivrons
gentiment et nous sacrifierons pas notre
industrie aéronautique automobile c'est
une folie ce que nous sommes en train de
faire nous sommes en train de sacrifier
sans milou 200000 emplois dans
l'industrie automobile pour
l'aéronautique nous allons faire pareil
donc je moi je suis favorable d'abord un
au choix des consommateurs et deux à
l'innovation
c'est à dire qu'on va trouver des
solutions vous savez le moteur
électrique pour la voiture vous savez
qu'il existe depuis toujours vous savez
qu avant le moteur
à essence il y avait le moteur
électrique
vous avez très envie de parler
d'industrie automobile je vous promets
on va à nancy dans quelques années
maintenant on va parler à une question
sur la lgv avec vous des personnes parce
que là aussi à des questions dans la
région dans la région de la personne et
reste alder oui eric zemmour à rester
bras cassés du de l'avion au train mais
vous l'avez évoqué simplement il ya un
projet majeur dans le sud ouest c'est le
prolongement de la lgv bordeaux paris la
paris bordeaux qui va aller vers
toulouse on est cette ligne bordeaux
toulouse puis un prolongement vers dax
c'est aussi ligne de fracture avec les
écologistes parce que voilà bordeaux
toulouse ou 5000 hectares d'espacés
naturels seront supprimés c
est ce que fait un partisan je n'ai si
vous êtes élu est ce que vous investirez
pense rires gênés d'abord
toulouse a longtemps refusé le tgv
justement pour privilégier l'avion
ça c'est une première chose moi je suis
je vous répète pour le train
pour le tgv ou lgv aussi sait si c'est
possible est-ce qu'il faut il faut
étudier cela combien de temps ça nous
fait gagner par rapport à être anormal
et il faut voir le rapport avantage c
est que l'avancé oui non mais là non
mais moi je sais que ça ne vaut pas le
coup abbas de détruire des paysages
effectivement pour cela c'est ya six et
dix minutes ils ont raison si si c'est
10 minutes ils ont raison maintenant ça
veut dire dans ce cas la queue leu leu
la sncf doit faire un effort conséquent
sur les lignes régionales il faut
absolument on a correct là le conseil
régional puisque l'on parlait tout à
l'heure ça c'est de la compétence du
conseil régional que
lier une vraiment de nouvelles je trouve
absolument impardonnable de la part de
la sncf d'avoir abandonné toutes ses
lignes régionales sous prétexte que ce
n'était pas rentable il faut absolument
des la politique du tout tgv jeu oui
mais ça la politique du tout tgv vous
savez
c'est une vieille politique c'est le
raisin années 80 on a fait ça s'était
très c'est très bien et et j'avais pour
nous permettre d'avoir arrêté
si c'est au détriment des lignes
régionales oui si on peut faire les deux
c'est formidable mais moi je suis pour
les régionales je suis si vous voulez et
c'est un des axes de ma campagne je
pense qu'il faut absolument
revivifier la france rurale je pense que
nous sommes arrivés si vous voulez c'est
une longue évolution historique en
vérité qui part du 19e siècle qui s'est
accélérée après la seconde guerre
mondiale vous savez nous étions le pays
qui avons le plus résisté à
l'urbanisation pour vous donner une idée
il y a plus de monde en france dans les
villes que dans les campagnes à partir
de 1931 le ce chiffre là osé en
angleterre et en allemagne c'est 1880 à
peu près on voyait on a longtemps
résisté et puis après on a accéléré
comme des fous parce qu'on s'est dit
c'est la condition de 2 du développement
de la de la prospérité donc aujourd'hui
on est allé trop loin et s'il faut des
metropolis et la promenade de tout
l'argent est parti dans les métropoles
l'argent de la mondialisation l'argent
de l'état dans les banlieues et dans les
centre-villes est ce que je voulais
pardonnez moi je finis il faut renverser
la vapeur et met beaucoup d'argent dans
les zones rurales qu'il faut favoriser
les transports or dit il est acquis même
si elles ne sont pas rentables et
comment est ce qu'on les finances on les
finance par l'état et parce que tout
simplement je vais vous dire c'est une
claque c'est à les collectivités qui
financent c'est l'étape finale a en
l'occurrence le là ça dépend le train
fait les collectivités locales mais vous
savez bien qu'il ya des transferts de
fonds mais ce que je veux dire je finis
simplement on a mis beaucoup d'argent
dans les villes et en particulier dans
les banlieues la fameuse politique de la
ville on l'avait pensé depuis 30 ans 100
milliards
je je je souhaite et je demande que l'on
transfère les feux de la politique de la
ville vous la politique d'aménagement
rural et des petites villes c'est c'est
une mesure fondamentale d'équité
aujourd'hui on dépense à peu près le
double pour les villes que pour les
zones rurales je veux faire l' inverse
et vous verrez que ça va changer donc
comment on finance avec cet argent même
à défaut c'est lamentable absolument
même si ça n'est pas rentable ça y est
c'est l'heure on va parler de l'auto
pour parler luc bouriane bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef adjoint l'est républicain élu qu'on
va donc évoquer avec vous des enjeux
relatifs à la construction automobile et
à la révolution électrique qui traverse
ce secteur c'est un sujet qui monte
partout en france un mets
particulièrement en lorraine et en
franche comté de régions dans lesquelles
l'industrie automobile occupe une place
de choix dans les économies locales
l'udc oui absolument reviennent donjon
monsieur zemmour donc année c'est la
construction automobile occupe une place
importante dans nos régions et donc dans
les pages de l'est républicain d'abord
bien sûr en franche comté à sochaux
berceau historique de la marque peugeot
à vesoul mais l'automobile pèse aussi
très lourd en lorraine où au delà de
différents sites industriels ce sont 250
sociétés qui sont en fait des sous
traitants des constructeurs tels que
renault oust et l'anti donc dans nos
régions en dépit des garanties des
promesses et même des investissements
des constructeurs le secteur s'inquiète
de cette conversion vers l'électrique
conduite à marche forcée vous l'avez
indiqué tout à l'heure les projections
indiquent que ce sont près de cent mille
emplois qui sont menacés en france par
l'avènement de l'électrique bref vous
brûliez d'envy d'en parler ça tombe bien
qu'elle serait donc votre politique et
surtout quelle est votre marge de
manoeuvre quelle serait-elle pour éviter
une telle saignée
dans les entreprises françaises et
notamment dans des régions comme la
lorraine qui ont déjà subi de plein
fouet de diverses vagues
vous êtes aimable de ne pas aller enfin
nommé pas mobile
mais c'est un vrai sujet mais non
inquiétude ce moment dans les airs
évidemment c'est un sujet fondamental on
a le droit 2-2 plaisante bien sûr un
sujet très sérieux
en vérité depuis des années
on sacrifie notre industrie pape répond
sur l'autel de l'idéologie verte et
écologistes on a sacrifié nos industries
qui était très puissant qu'en france la
chimie on a oublié il n'y a plus
d'industrie chimique en france elle a
été mise en eau en inde et en chine la
pharmacie on s'est rendu compte qu'on
fabriquait plus rien en france je me
souvenais la polémique sur le
paracétamol bon pourquoi d'après vous
pourquoi on était une c'était une des
industries phare de la france et coûte
moins cher de le faire ailleurs pas
seulement chère madame je vous assure
pas seulement c'est aussi parce qu'il ya
trop de normes en france et donc les
industriels en ont marre et donc ils
mettent leur usine en inde mais aussi
parce que ça coûte moins cher les deux
mais les poussettes vous savez bien que
les salaires des travailleurs indiens et
chinois ont beaucoup monté et pourtant
les usines ne reviennent pas parce qu'il
n'y a pas que le salaire il y a aussi
les normes et donc en fait on exporte
notre pollution notre notre co2 mais
après il revient il revient en un
produit bon en produits consommés
incomber sur la vie berg automobile 12e
mais je le mets c'est il faut toujours
vous savez remettre dans le contexte
qu'on voit l'évolution l'automobile
c'est la nouvelle cible c'est la
nouvelle victime qu'est ce qu'on fait on
fait on va autre journaliste l'a dit il
ya cent mille emplois en jeu c'est
colossal colossal en plus c'était une
industrie mme guérin industrie française
compétitive donc on va la sacrifier on
était très fort dans les moteurs
thermiques on était très fort dans les
moteurs diesel qui avaient énormément
progressé qui en vérité et ai été très
peu coupable dans le réchauffement
climatique était devenu très peu
coupable
pour une industrie pour une industrie
électrique qui pour lesquels pour
lesquelles les chinois sont en avance
les américains sont en avance sur nous
donc on va encore apporter d'aidé dont
va encore sacrifier notre industrie est
en plus mais monsieur carlos tavares le
patron de toujours qu'est devenu cet
élan est ainsi maintenant là a tout dit
mieux que moi il lui il sait un expert
il a dit cette politique européenne
accepté par monsieur macro est une folie
elle va il faut détruire industrie
automobile oui sur les huit villes et
qui feront revenir en arrière oui il
faut plus de variété les lélés les
consommateurs choisiront oui il faut
plus de variété oui ils font comment
j'ai eu à voyager c'est zemmour et moi
toute la stratégie de l'état à l'heure
actuelle et nous construire par exemple
des gigas factory dans notre région des
hauts de france des usines des grandes
usines de batteries électriques toute
une filière vous dis pas la douleur dit
on arrête je ne dis pas non mais
vraiment non mais je comprends votre
question je ne dis pas qu'il faut
abandonner la filière électrique je dis
qu'il faut diversifier il ne faut pas
mettre tous ses oeufs dans le même
panier c'est tout ce que je dis surtout
quand le panier est percé parce que le
panier est plus fourni chez les chinois
que chez nous c'est tout ce que je dis
il faut peut-être avoir les mêlées c'est
le tort à l'industrie automobile
d'investir dans les fameuses batteries
mais vous m'accordez que pour l'instant
on va ça on va tout acheter chez les
chinois vous êtes d'accord avec moi donc
le temps est-il ce même dans les hauts
de france voilà donc le temps vous savez
ils sont malins les chinois ils vont ils
vont ils vont saper tous nos efforts ils
ont bien compris on est en train de leur
donner les clés du camion c'est le cas
de le dire
peut-être un dernier mot avec vous sur
ce sujet oui même si je me permets de
prolonger parce que la question c'était
quelle marge de manoeuvre auriez-vous or
là l'europe a décidé d'interdire la
vente de tout véhicule neuf à moteur
diesel ou essence dès 2035 mais vous
savez ce qu'est ce qu'un président de la
république pourrait faire mais vous
savez monsieur l'europe
comment vous dire ce n'est pas
dieu qui descend ce n'est pas mon fils
qui descend du mont sinaï avec l'étape
de la loi donnée par dieu ça se discute
la france c'est une association de
nations l'europe il faut jamais
l'oublier monsieur mac on a tendance à
un peu à l'oublier moi pas la commission
de bruxelles n'est pas le dictateur au
dessus du président de la république
française c'est d'abord les états
européens qui décide donc on peut
toujours renégocier négocier on peut
toujours dire que là on ne respecte pas
là on va en demande du temps il ya des
négociations on n'est pas obligé tout le
temps comme le gouvernement de monsieur
macron de se coucher devant les
injonctions de bruxelles et vassal et
d'un de ses symboles y trouve que comme
style antique juste excusez moi rien un
groupe comme c'était lentilles vous
l'avez dit le fait peut-être un recul en
mai à enclencher déjà investit déjà très
fortement il dit que ça va être une
catastrophe
pardonnez moi c'est pas être à reculons
c'est dire on va à la catastrophe
on est d'obliger on a le pistolet sur la
tempe donc on le fait mais on vous
prévient ça sera une catastrophe c'est
ça qu'on disait monsieur me dit monsieur
tabary il dit pas bon allez je le fais
quand même c atteint à reculons non il
dit vous allez à la catastrophe je vous
aurais prévenu merci lui bouriane merci
on va parler d'un dossier symbolique csu
de l'assam dans l'aveyron un exemple
très concret
333 personnes salariés de la société
aveyronnaise métallurgie ont reçu leur
lettre de licenciement
ils occupent leur usine depuis
soixante-quatre jours et disent que leur
activité a été délocalisée vous
président de la république qu'est ce que
vous faites est ce que vous interdisez
les délocalisations pour éviter ce genre
de sylvain roussel le propose est ce que
vous êtes d'accord
todd communiste on sait où ça mène
maintenant c'est comment ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que l on a connu le
communisme a existé dans toute l'europe
de l'est entre vous interdire non mais
on ne peut pas interdire vous savez il
ya des choses qu'on peut pas faire un
peu on peut sauter sur sa chaise en
disant on interdit on interdit on a
perdu mais c'est pas vrai
voilà maintenant
essayons d'être réaliste et de boire ce
qui se passe vraiment encore une fois
encore une fois il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vont trouver prétexte
de cette transition écologique à marche
forcée pour délocaliser ici parce qu'en
vérité c'est ce que je vous ai dit vous
avez eu l'impression que je faisais une
diversion mais non c'est ce qui s'est
passé pour la chimie c'est ce qui s'est
passé pour la pharmacie on a dit bon ben
ya des normes très strictes en europe
qu'est ce qu'on fait non c'est pas qu'on
arrête cette industrie on l'a
délocalisent vers des pays qui se
moquent complètement nos normes et les
renault et peugeot merci donc ça va
continuer saison qu'est ce que peugeot
où sont alors le 6 juin quand les propos
de fabien roussel il dit que c'est
presque une trahison envers la nation de
délocaliser la production en chine est
ce que vous estimez que c'est en effet
une trahison oui c'est une trahison mais
cette trahison c'est le gouvernement
français qui en est responsable et c'est
bruxelles qui en est responsable les les
les grands groupes le fonds soient
contraints soit encore une fois je ne
veux pas être naïf soit ils profitent de
la situation
celle qui leur a donné la possibilité
d'en profiter mais qu'est ce que vous
dites aux salariés de la sam ce matin si
vous êtes élue le 24 avril kg qui va se
passer pour eux je moi je vais le moi je
suis là pour protéger l'industrie
française et pour réindustrialiser donc
j'ai tout un plan pour la
réindustrialisation jeu j'espère qu'on
pourra parler c'est le moment à les y
apparaît très bien
en fait nous avons une industrie qui a
vraiment pris la poudre d'escampette
pour vous donner les chiffres qui sont
maintenant à peu connu on avait une
industrie qui représentait dans les
années 80 24 % de la richesse nationale
c'est ce que c'est encore en allemagne
ça représente 24% en italie 20 % nous
nous sommes devenus à 13% même certaines
statistiques donnent 11% c'est vous dire
en fait on n'a quasiment plus une
industrie à part quelques pôles
l'aéronautique dont parlait le luxe est
c'est un don donc il faut absolument
rien du se réaliser car cette
désindustrialisation s'est cette
désindustrialisation qui provoque aussi
le fond de la sphère de la discussion
sur le pouvoir d'achat combien de
déclassement il ya un grand déclassement
des français à cause de la
désindustrialisation
donc évidemment si vous voulez on a
ouvert les frontières à tout va on a
fait rentrer la chine dans l' omc et
hugo voyant ça vient d'où locales à jour
le constat mais qu'est ce que vous
faites n'ont pas alors donc d'abord
d'abord il faut bien comprendre que les
entreprises françaises souffrent d'un
excès d'eau normes je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure et de charges et d'impôts donc
allègement des noms allègement des
normes joël je crée un haut commissariat
à la jeunesse du jury sera t'il attend
des simplifications administratives pour
nettoyer tous les codes les normes et
ses portraits deuxièmement baisse des
charges
impôts de production ses impôts imbécile
que les entreprises payent avant même
d'avoir fait un sou de bénéfices moins
10 milliards
d'individus qu'est ce que vous proposez
vous remarquez vous remarqué que là
aussi c'est comme la discussion de tout
à l'heure il c'est comme le nucléaire il
se réveille au nom de la caisse qui vous
proposez moi j'aurais repose 30
milliards sur le quinquennat de perdre
gros de production ça ne vient pas en
ces mois de 10 milliards par an s'il ya
pas mal au nom mais est-ce que ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que c'était déjà
de 10 milliards par an c'est ce que
prône en garde il faut un vernement
après on sait pas ce qu'ils vont faire à
suivre plusieurs années
les 10 milliards moi je vous dis 30
milliards en tout donc c'est pas la même
chose on sait pas ce qu'ils vont faire
ils n'annoncent pas 20 milliards 30
milliards vous comprenez ce que je veux
dire
selon lui non pas nécessairement
deuxièmement je propose également de
baisser en tout cas de permettre à
beaucoup de pme de payer l'impôt sur les
sociétés au taux réduit vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya le taux normal 5 %
il ya le taux réduit de 15%
aujourd'hui au delà de 36000 euros je
crois de bénéfices on passe alors à au
taux normal je propose d'augmenter ce
plafond à 300000 euros pour permettre à
beaucoup d'entreprises de d'en profiter
troisièmement je propose également pour
permettre aux pme de grossir et de ne
pas se vendre à fond d'investissement
américain ou à des chinois comme cela se
fait beaucoup de d'exonérer les
entreprises familiales de droits de
transmission de droits de douane à 2 2
oui c'est juste qu'il faut qu'on passe
un message
est pas fini
est-ce qu'il ya le banc parce que je
veux pas qu'on croie que y'a que des
baisses de charges il ya aussi le le
versant parce que moi je suis pas un
dogmatique vous savez je suis pas y
avait aussi le versant étatique c'est à
dire que je veux que l'état protège nos
entreprises contre les investissements
étrangers qui sont là uniquement pour
nous voler nos technologies donc voila
et deuxièmement je suis pour un fonds
souverain adossé au livret a parce que
les entreprises françaises manquent
cruellement de capitaux et donc vous
savez on a une épargne colossale et donc
je vous trouve très beau coup ils ont
donc le fonds souverain adossé aux
livres est apte pourrait alimenter nos
entreprises et
dernière chose si vous me permettez
je propose la création d'un d'un patrice
corre savez sur le modèle d'une minute
voilà vous connaissez ça donc qui
permettrait de voir
le degré de fabrication en france de
tous les produits parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui contrairement à hier les
français sont prêts mais de même à
mettre un petit peu plus d'argent pour
acheter un produit français et donc il
faut leur dire on va parler d'un hôtel
matin il y revient derrière chose moi
j'vous dernière chose vraiment dernière
chose je veux que la commande publique
favorise les entreprises françaises et
je proposerai à l'europe une réforme des
marchés publics pour permettre c'est mon
ami yves jégo vous savez l'ancien
ministre de nicolas sarkozy qu'il a
proposé que chaque pays garde 25% de sa
commande publique pour des entreprises
nationales on avait je le ferai voilà si
le ferai mais c'est que j'arriverai à
réaliser on va parler de sécurité on va
là marseille retrouver gilles aymeric
avis bon jong il à merci beaucoup d'être
avec nos directeurs des rédactions du
journal la provence et avoue guilhem
oui effectivement bonjour eric zemmour
en entendu hier le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin assuré et
bien que à l'heure du bilan si on
regarde sur la la mandature d'emmanuel
macro on constatera une baisse continue
de la délinquance moi je suis à
marseille vous êtes venus d'ailleurs
vous même à marseille fin novembre on
voit bien ses règlements de comptes
successifs ont fait peut-être pas tout à
fait le même constat vue de marseille
que vu de paris comment selon vous en
règle ce problème de la délinquance dans
une ville comme marseille ça je suis
venu à marseille et je m'en souviendrai
longtemps
je pense à lévis d'abord sur cette
question oui cette question fondamentale
monsieur darmanin
soit ment effrontément soit vie dans des
sages il y a partout une explosion de la
délinquance un an sauvagement
généralisée de la cid de la société
française il y à
350 milles agression du premier semestre
2021 1800 agressions par jour tout tout
tout explose les chiffres de violences
sexuelles les chiffres d'agression les
chiffres de vols les chiffres de meurtre
les le monsieur monsieur bauer quelle au
grand criminologue français a établi un
taux voyez 2 2 2d des meurtres et kiki
et qui a doublé mais dans les années 70
aujourd'hui il est alors qu'est ce que
je fais il faut quand même oui monsieur
damas lundi tout va bien madame la
marquise et chip starwing quand même
fait alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait toujours
comme d'habitude moi je raisonne
diagnostic donc mesure je pose le
diagnostic pourquoi on a un tel ans
sauvagement
première raison la mère de toutes les
raisons l'immigration
deuxième raison le laxisme judiciaire
tha ce sont pour moi les deux raisons
fondamentales de l'explosion de la
délinquance immigration j'arrête
l'immigration je veux l'immigration zéro
immigration zéro tout le monde tout le
monde dit que c'est une mesure qui n'a
aucun sens juridique à mais puisqu'elle
impose de remettre en cause certains
textes fondamentaux vous le savez
pertinemment absolument et donc
remettrai en fermentant monsieur textes
fondamentaux excusez moi mais c'est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme je
sais c'est ce prix le tout je sais mais
attendez monsieur attendait mais c'est à
moi c'est important de le dire vous
laisser mais je vais vous voulez
présidents remis
abandonnes ton ce pilier de la
démocratie qu'est la déclaration des
droits d'un char monsieur le pilier de
la démocratie c'est le peuple
d'accord démocratie si rien n'est fait
ces déclarations d'une immense c'est le
peuple c'est les représentants du joueur
je ne remet absolument pas en cause la
déclaration des droits de l'homme je ne
remet absolument pas en cause les
principes mêmes de l'état de droit je
remets en cause en revanche
la liberté qu'on les juge
on sait qu'on sionnel conseil d'état et
c'est d'imposer leur doxa au peuple qui
n'en veut pas donc à partir de
maintenant nous ferons un référendum le
peuple tranchera je mettrai toutes les
mesures que j'encours que je propose
c'est à dire la fin du regroupement
familial parce que vous avez raison tout
cela l'immigration zéro est impossible
vous avez tout à fait raison dans les
grès le droit à tout non dans le cadre
juridique actuel vous avez employé ce
mot et boudry et nous avons pris le bon
mot moi je change le cadre jury de
changer la constitution non vous savez
au temps du général de gaulle je crois
qu'ils connaissent et un peu sa
constitution la défaite oui il peut plus
que jamais le conseil constitutionnel
n'aurait fait ce que vous dites c'est à
dire que le concept fonctionne elle ne
se permettait pas de prendre un principe
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme pour juger une loi parce que ce
n'était pas prévu dans le cadre
constitutionnel
c'est le juge concerné le cas inventé ce
rôle le 16 juillet 71 je peux vous faire
tout l'historique j'ai déjà beaucoup et
elle s'est bien mis donc donc c'est déjà
bout de ce judiciaire donc moi je dis au
conseil constitionnel à partir de
maintenant sur les sujets comme
l'immigration qui engage la survie de la
france
je demande au peuple de trancher et vous
savez qu'il ya puisque vous parlez du
droit une jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel de 1962 qui dit quand le
peuple s'exprime par référendum moi
lille devant n'occupe pas depuis depuis
cette disposition n'a plus jamais été
ils ont égalisé et ben je leur prends je
leur dis surtout que excuses
énorme et elle garde-fous
avez-vous dès lors que vous supprimez la
pression le conseil constitutionnel
ecoutez-moi deux choses de choses vous
savez le droit encore une fois j'ai pris
cette comparaison que je crois en 80 le
droit ce n'est pas les tables de la loi
descendu du mont sinaï c'est une veine
on a les marxistes disait jadis que
c'était le produit des rapports de force
de la société ce n'est pas ça ne tombe
pas du ciel vous savez qui est président
du conseil constitionnel aujourd'hui
monsieur fadli ancien premier ministre
socialiste vous savez qui est président
de la cour des comptes monsieur
moscovici ancien ministre socialiste
vous savez qui est président
vice-président puisqu'il n'ya pas de
danses et
démonstrations jeux vous enlevez jeu qui
est vice-président du conseil d'état
monsieur tabarot qui était un ancien
membre des cabinets de madame aubry et
de monsieur kouchner donc en vérité
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
l'état de droit c'est l'étape socialiste
ce sont les socialistes qui ne
représente plus que 3 % dans le pays qui
dirige le pays et bien qu'à travers lui
à travers les tic à travers l'état de
droit les juges qui sont dirigées par
des socialistes
excusez-moi posent leur vie
j'aurai on n'est pas ma question le
référendum par le peuvent vous voulez
redonner le pouvoir au peuple je
comprends tout à fait la large bien mais
dès lors qu'une le pilier de la de la
démocratie actuelle c'est une sorte de
contrôle des lois pas en effet des juges
il ya soit leur avis sur la base de
textes fondamentaux encore il
termine président enlevez vous ce
garde-fou
cdd conséquent si ce n'est la condition
est ce que vous trouvez normal que au
nom du principe de fraternité liberté
égalité fraternité
le conseil constitutionnel est absous un
passeur de clandestins est ce que vous
trouvez normal qu'au nom des grands
principes la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme nous ait empêché d'expulser
vers l'algérie un jihadiste moi je ne
trouve pas ça normal moi j'estime que
cela c'est une surinterprétation en
fonction d'une idéologie d'ailleurs je
renard
remarque que les juges qui sont si
pointilleux sur la liberté quand il
s'agit d' immigration quand ils assez
dajic d'enfer on a déjà répondu avec
beaucoup mais constitutionnel je vais
répondre je vais répondre aux
balcons t il pas du conseil oui parce
que j'ai pas répondu à la question c'est
ce que je dis aux balais il va le
conseil constitionnel le conséquence
elle garde son rôle de contrôle des lois
ce que je dis c'est que 1 quand le
peuple s'exprime par référendum il doit
s'incliner c'est ça la démocratie que
deux nous ferons une réforme
constitutionnelle de l'article 55 qui
modifiera les termes de l'article 55 qui
dit aujourd'hui que les traités sont
supérieures aux lois et qui permet aux
juges deux ex super d'un texte
international pour annuler une loi je
modifierai et je dirais que les lois
postérieur sont supérieurs aux
conventions et aux traités
internationaux maintenant je veux
répondre à la sécurité qui attend et
consolidation je disais immigration
c'est la mère de toutes les batailles
c'est pour ça que nous avons une
délinquance aussi explosif c'est à cause
de l'immigration donc si on arrêtait
l'immigration immigration zéro il y aura
plus de délinquance il y en aura il y
aura quasiment plus oui à ça j'en suis
sûr
deuxièmement deuxièmement cirque avec
des immigrés qui sont délinquants
d'autres oui en tout cas des immigrés ou
des enfants d'immigrés c'est le français
ils seront alors justement on va traiter
ça laissez moi finir deuxième question
deuxième question donc je supprime le
regroupement familial le droit d'asile
ne sera plus qu'une poignée de gens qui
seront et pas 130000 comme aujourd'hui
les étudiants au pareil les ventes
toutes les sources de deux des
migrations gelé tard un accord je
supprime la et me je supprime les ms la
crise sociale non contributives aux
étrangers je supprime le droit du sol
c'est à dire qu'on ne sera plus
français parce qu'on est né en france de
parents étrangers nés de parents
français voilà ça c'est les grandes
mesures pour arrêter l'immigration
j'expulse les chômeurs étrangers de plus
de six mois et nous arrivons à la
sécurité pourquoi il y avait autant de
délinquance aussi sa cause du laxisme
judiciaire trois raisons très vite
d'abord
l'idéologie de beaucoup de juges qui est
une idéologie
gauche façonné jadis par le syndicat de
la magistrature je dis bien besoin d'une
jauge entre les juges comme un pas du
tout pas du tout je vous savez je vais
vous dire je pense que la démocratie
c'est le peuple et que le goût le
général de gaulle à arracher le pouvoir
aux parlementaires car il estimait que
il avait un pouvoir excessif et que le
peuple ne dirigeait plus le pays c'est
la quatrième république et c'est donc le
la 5ème république quitte à trets a
aujourd'hui nous avons le même problème
avec les juges c'est à dire qu'ils ont
un pouvoir excessif et ils ont pris le
pouvoir au peuple et donc je vous le
rendre au peuple donc la justice le
laxisme des juges donc je vais à
instaurer des peines plancher minimales
que les juges devront
appliquer appliquée deuxièmement une
véritable perpétuité et n'ont pas 18 ans
comme aujourd'hui adèle slam avec moi ne
sortira pas de prison jamais
troisièmement
nous supprimons aussi le régime de
réduction des peines savez j'ai été très
frappée par une histoire ya quelques
années de madame natacha mougel que
c'est important cette jeune femme a été
violée et tuée par un criminel qui avait
déjà violé et tué équipes devaient avoir
une peine de dix ans
était chez nous à marcq en baroeul merci
et des histoires comme ça il y en a des
tas c'est plus possible donc donc il y
aura après je continue parce que c'est
quand même important
jeu j'exclus seraient les délinquants
étrangers pour vous donner une idée sur
les 60000 délinquants aujourd'hui en
prison il y en a quinze mille étrangers
je les expulserait jeu des chemins
menant dès maintenant je déchoir de la
nationalité française tous les doubles
nationaux déchéance de nationalité qui a
déjà été refusée par le conseil
constitutionnel en club ça sera dans mon
référendum est comme ça le conseil sia
ne crois rien de choses à dire beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de choses dans la 40e
mais ça vous avez tout à fait raison
vous laisser expulsé vers où berlin
sachant que les états d'origine c'est
une question d'ailleurs il disait qu'il
refuse aussi même tous leurs clandestins
n'ait laissé passer bien aujourd'hui
siens laissez passer consulaires un bras
de fer entre certains pays et le
gouvernement français sur ce sujet
absolument vous avez raison madame on
fait comment on fait comment je vais
vous dire on fait un vrai bras de fer
s'est pas semblant comme monsieur macro
la suppression des visas ce n'était pas
un vrai batteur il le fait pas il le dit
mais il ne fait pas comme toujours avec
monsieur macro moi je supprime les visas
y compris pour les dirigeants des pays
qui ne signent pas les laisser passer au
clair et qu'ils ne reprennent pas leurs
ressortissants 2 je supprime l'aide au
développement
3 je saisi les biens des dirigeants
étrangers 4 je bloque les fonds de la
western union qui transfère les fonds
des étrangers d'ici vers les lieux un
pays je continue sur les mesures excusez
moi mais parce que par ce biais là qu'il
mesure que arnaud montebourg je pense à
un moment donné avait avant la prise
dans mon programme mais je mérite c'est
la retient de rester et c'est très
dommage lorsque vous dites mans où il a
retiré au bout de 24 vous pénaliser des
gens qui n'ont absolument rien à voir
avec le problème oui et pourquoi rendre
rendre responsable des gens qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec avec la
décision d'état étrangers je suis désolé
ils sont ressortissants de ces pays et
je vais vous dire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui dans nombreux pays africains
aux nombreux pays africains les
transferts de fonds venus des immigrés
de chez nous et le premier budget de la
de la balance des paiements de ces pays
donc si vous voulez ça permet à ces pays
d'avoir la tête hors de l'eau donc c'est
déjà de comptabilité de la aux habitants
leurs ressortissants ne sont pas
responsables je pense que c'est les
états qui sont responsables de la
politique de leur politique il n'y a
aucune raison que des pays que nous
aidons par exemple je pense au mali nous
avons des jeunes soldats qui meurent
pour eux et ces gens là refusent
dédaigneusement de nous reprendre les
clandestins que nous renvoyons mais pour
qui nous prend pour l'afghanistan où la
boue la syrie est ce qu'on fait puisque
est vraiment de questions de renvoyer
des gens hors de question de l'envoi je
pense si on a accepté mon nom je vais
vous savez c'est bien que je n'accepte
sur l'axé mais moi quand on est gay mais
quand tout à l'heure vous nous dites que
si à plus d'immigration il ya plus de
délinquance parce que tous les
délinquants sont des immigrés ou des
enfants d'immigration ou des enfants de
l'immigration donc des enfants français
vous rendez bien avec ce que vous bien
sûr mais je vous ai dit qu'est ce que je
fais pour ceux qui sont là et qui sont
français je vous ai dit tout ce que je
faisais d'accord je pourrais rajouter
las pour les mineurs je réduis la la
majorité pénale à 16 ans et je supprime
mais elle va s'y est bien attendez tous
les élans n'aime pas des immigrés ou des
enfants désirés pas si excusez moi allez
voir dans l'est mais vous tenez sont
allés voir aller voir dans les prisons
françaises et vous verrez vous dites
vous même que ceux ci le chiffre était
est important ce n'est pas la totalité
des des détenus des prisons françaises
si vous savez au japon il
ya bon il n'y a quasiment pas
d'immigration les prisons sont vides
posez vous la question c'est un peu
rapide comme raisonnement c'est non
c'est par rapide c'est évidemment ce
n'est pas du 100 % mais je vous assure
que si on arrête l'immigration on
retrouvera la tranquillité dans ce pays
et si et c'est l'export etc ça
n'enlèvera pas la délinquance elle et
sera marginal comme dans tout pays
normal aujourd'hui nous avons une
délinquance folle un ans sauvagement
devenus des mesures et le plaquent c'est
la conséquence d'une immigration folle
j'avais tous les chiffres d'il ya
quelques jours le japon aussi des lois
extrêmement coercitives qui limite et
oui mais nous aurons des lois
extrêmement coercitives d'où la défense
la défense excusable juste un mot
là-dessus nous préciser parce qu'on a un
peu l'impression parce par cette
expression que vous autorisez finalement
c'est un permis tu es s et moi c'est de
nouveau parce que si je expliquer qu'on
soit clair c'était samedi soir à cannes
vous tenir un meeting et là vous avez
dit que si vous êtes élu vous introduire
la notion de défense excusable c'est à
dire que c'est un commerçant se fait
attaquer peut riposter tiens policiers
cette élection légitime défense
santé absolument j'ai surprise et vous
bien mais je vais vous dire est ce que
est ce que vous connaissez bien sûr la
suisse est ce que vous trouvez que la
suisse et est un est un western
permanent et que tous les suisses ont
droit de tuer pour répondez moi non donc
c'est une notion du droit suisse que
j'ai que j'ai prise dans le pont suzanne
à genève on m'a expliqué cela j'ai
trouvé ça très bien d'ailleurs s'est
dotée suisse aussi que je prends
l'expulsion des chômeurs étrangers de
plus de six mois voyez par exemple celle
en suisse c'est un étranger vient
travailler en france si au bout de six
mois il n'a plus de travail vous
l'expulser ça va te mesurer exactement
le canada au sud les états unis vous
savez au bout de deux mois même et
donc sur la défense espère la dépense
exclu qu'est ce que c'est c'est simple
aujourd'hui pour la légitime défense la
légitime défense pour être légal à des
contraintes telles qu'il n'y en a jamais
et que les mêmes les policiers vous dit
vous savez j'ai vu beaucoup de policiers
ils vous disent en fait on a peur sorti
notre âme car on sait que l on va se
retrouver au trou qu'on va se retrouver
en garde à vue que notre carrière va
être fini conte etc etc je veux changer
cela aujourd'hui c'est les policiers et
les seals honnêtes citoyens qui ont peur
et pas les voyons là ce que vous je veux
aller plus voyons et peur ce que vous
dites ça va au delà une dernière
question oui seulement au delà des faux
l'acier donc ça va vous parler des
simples citoyens absolument avec la
défense excuse à peut-être le bijoutier
comme stéphane turquie ont été condamnés
il n'aurait à la légitime défense
n'avait pas été retenu puisque je le
rappelle il avait tiré sur quelqu'un
dans le dos qui sont qui s'enfuyaient
pour vous ce serait accepter non ce qui
est accepté c'est qu' il n'y ait plus de
proportionnalité vous savez aujourd'hui
c'est très strict il doit y avoir une
proportionnalité
de la menace de la menace moi je pense
qu'il ne doit plus avoir de
proportionnalité les voyous doivent
prendre leur risques
s'ils l'attaquent quelqu'un c'est eux
qui doivent avoir peur ce n'est plus ce
que les policiers ou les citoyens
l'instrument est ce que vous
on n'a même plus le temps pour guilhem
on va remercier guilhem qui avaient
encore une question pour vous et on
s'excuse vraiment auprès de dilemme mais
il nous reste deux minutes pour quelques
questions politiques d'abord vous en ai
toutes vos parrainages ce matin ça va
mieux c'est à dire bah c'est pas non
mais c'est vrai mais moi je fais je suis
honnête josé ruiz encore non j'ai pas
reçu une aide simplement
d'abord la médiatisation et je vous
remercie puisque j'ai brûlé plus de
particuliers mais on est inséré le but
oui bon pour moi c'était but a fait
prendre conscience à beaucoup de maires
peuvent suite été un scandale que je ne
suis pas candidat deuxièmement l'arrivée
de mes amis guillaume pelletier philippe
de villiers jérôme rivière gilbert
collard voyez tous ces gens et ben et
ils ont ils ont appelé des maires ils
ont discuté vous savez quand à mr
les républicains qui vous donnera non
pas du tout non non c d vous savez
madame pécresse a dit
celui qui celui qui donne à parrainage
quand il est l air sera sanctionné eric
zemmour sera sanctionné donc on a ces
choses sont claires nom des gens qui ont
soit des divers droite soit des gens qui
pensent que c'est la démocratie et qui
ne sont pas d'accord avec moi donc
effectivement nous nous arrivons à 4 100
parrainages donc évidemment ce n'est pas
fini car il faut vous savez tous les
spécialistes nous explique qu'il en faut
six cent mille sept cents voilà parce
qu'il ya des idées de divertissement
très bien mais c'est ce qui arrive
vraiment exact donc vous êtes normes
d'agrément
je suis raisonnablement optimiste mais
ce matin combien de promesses je vous
dis à peu près on doit être pas loin de
400 lettres à 390 me allez une dernière
question mais lui alors cnbc c'est une
dernière question excusez moi mais
est ce qu'on peut imaginer quand même
vous échouez à la présidentielle une
option comme pour tous les candidats
qu'est-ce qui se passe après cette
élection est ce que vous arrêtez là
votre aventure politique personnelle non
je n'arrêterai pas là une aventure
politique et je serai élu président et
je vais vous dire pourquoi un mot parce
que si vous voulez je suis l'alternative
à 40 ans de blocage de la vie politique
par le génie tacticien de françois
mitterrand qui a bloqué et qui a séparé
un peuple de droite qui doit se
rassembler et je suis le seul à leur
assemblée c'est à dire que la théorie du
cordon sanitaire je les ai expliqué à
cannes samedi mais ça fait 20 ans que je
l'expliquais dans mes livres
j'en ai pour une minute vraiment le
cordon sanitaire qu'est ce que c'est
c'est d'une part une droite qui se
prétend républicaine parce que tout
simplement la gauche lui a mis sa petite
médaille en lui disant toi tu es gentil
qu'ils ont enjoint pas tu ne mangeras
pas tu ne fera pas de mal à la gauche
tuez républicaine et les autres qui sont
les parias front national et c'est moi
avec moi il n'ya plus de paria il n'y a
plus de corps dont c'est l'union des
droites le peuple de droite se
rassemblent et c'est la seule façon
m'entendais c'est la seule façon de
battre emmanuel macron est de battre le
6 mai civile mais attendez attendez le
battait amazing attend des jeux sur mac
ou non mais c'est important c'est
important et je suis le seul à
rassembler les droites on le voit dans
les gens qui me rejoignent aujourd'hui
les politiques qui me rejoignent de l
air et du rassemblement le ça et on le
vit à leiria qui a pédalé dans les
séries mentorat ce n'est pas fini vous
savez il ya des gens chez l'élève qui
aujourd'hui parce qu'eric ciotti
dimanche il a dit laurent guillaume
pelletier personne d'autre mais oui on
verra on verra vous inquiétez pas eric
ciotti l'eau pauvres vous savez il dit
ce qui peut ils avaient dit jamais avec
jean christophe lagarde et jean
christophe lagarde vous avez dit jamais
le centriste avait dit jamais avec eric
ciotti le pauvre eric ciotti il doit
avaler dix mille couleurs parce que
madame pécresse s'est empressé d'aller
faire alliance avec monsieur lagarde qui
rejette tout ce que dit monsieur ciotti
donc on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient
jusqu'ici toujours madame pécresse mais
c'est son problème c'est son problème
s'il veut être sacrifiés et ses idées
sacrifier campi pour lui c'est celui-ci
dans un grand mouvement politique le
manque en reconquête est déjà à 85 mille
adhérents en un mois et demi on n'a
jamais vu ça c'est comme les amours d'un
mineur vous êtes élu il vous faut une
majorité parlementaire est-ce que vous
travaillez sur législatives combien vous
espérez de députés et avec qui vous
constituer cette fois je veux dire
combien j'espère de député ce que je
dirais un objectif non non non non vous
savez les français ont compris la
logique de la vème république le
président est élu il lui donne une
majorité on l'a vu pour emmanuel macron
qui n'avait pas de parti qui a pris ses
députés sur internet et on le voit le
résultat ils sont pitoyables
et sur internet il ya nous avons des
alliés nous avons des gens comme jean
frédéric poisson et son mouvement via
nous avons madame trochut voyez nous
montrer à nos rivaux toile est mise pour
les logiciels et se sera le boudin fin
merci eric zemmour merci on avait encore
votre question on n'a plus le temps bah
oui si j'aimerais éviter
d'avoir été alors si évidemment on va
poursuivre cette série d'émissions
spéciales avec d'autres candidats merci
beaucoup eric zemmour d'avoir été le
premier invité merci julien lécuyer
murphy oil bertrand et merci à nos
quatre journalistes de la presse
régionale en région
[Musique]